the main focus of this curriculum which
you have probably heard a number of
times is not to memorize spelling words
the focus is to concentrate on the
phonograms and spelling rules that
students have learned to help them spell
words it's giving them tools to spell
hundreds and hundreds of words as
opposed to memorizing lists of spelling
words so in everything you do whether
you're working with phonograms
or on spelling rules your concentration
should be on the sounds that are within
those words we are gonna take a look at
the markings that we talked about in the
previous video with the phonograms
students know how to do this so this is
something that as a parent you should be
aware of and know how to do as well
students learn that they're to underline
photographs of two or more letters they
learn that a phonograms first sound is
not marked sounds other than the first
sound of a phonogram are numbered they
underline of all saying its name and
they double underline a silent
phonograms the majority of the rules
that they learn are learned through an
introduction of the rules but there are
a few more specific ones that are
written and words are marked based upon
those rules so the first thing that
we're going to talk about is the
syllable rule or syllables so students
learn that a syllable is a chunk of a
word and it acts just like a word so the
phonograms and rules that apply to a
word can also apply to a syllable how do
they know where a syllable is in a word
or how many syllables a word has how do
you know that so these students have
learned that every syllable contains a
vowel and when we pronounce a vowel our
jaw drops so they learn a I owe you that
your mouth is opening every time you say
evolve so when you say a syllable that
contains about your jaw will drop your
mouth will open in your jaw will drop
awesome so let's use the example of the
word phonogram so a student would put
their hand under their chin and they
would say that word phone nah gram their
chin drops three times so they know that
that word has three syllables in a
syllable is marked by a space and a dot
so students have learned that so parents
you need to know about that space and
that dot as well
now that they have the syllables they
can apply the rules and the phonograms
that they know and the markings to those
smaller sections or chunks of a word in
addition to those markings the other
major ones that students learn are the
silent final e rules and those are
actually memorized now on the sheet that
you will receive you will have all of
this but just to do a quick
understanding of what they involve I'm
going to go through the six different
rules for silent final e so again
students learn at this letter because it
is a silent phonogram gets a double
underline they learn that when a vowel
says its name it gets underlined and the
consonants gonna join in at this time
also this is rule number one this silent
final e makes this vowel say its name so
they learn this is silent final e roll
one so you'll have that on the sheet
that you have that you have access to
and you will also have those markings to
understand how that works in this word
students learn that English words do not
end with u or V they must have an e at
the end to finish the word second rule
that they become familiar with
they learn that when a silent final is
at the end of a word it changes the sea
to its second sound so it's not gonna
say it's now gonna say and in the case
of a G it would not say it would say G
so they learned that is number three and
they learn to mark a word and you will
have access to seeing how that's marked
and there and the reasoning behind it
students learn as we said in the
beginning when they learn about
syllables that every syllable needs to
have a vowel so a silent e neeps oops
a silent e needs to the silent e needs
to get added to get that vowel into the
syllable they learn too that the silent
final E is added to let you know that
this s is not a suffix it is a part of
the basic word and then their last one
is called their last rule that they
learn is called odd job numbers six
which means that E is doing a number of
odd little things and it occurs less
often it might have been an e that was
there in a pronunciation long ago it
might be an e that's there to
differentiate between homophone
homophones it might be an e that's there
to extend a word they're all just sort
of little less specific rules that fall
there these first five are the ones that
they know well so you need to know well
so if you're working on spelling words
with them you can understand what's
happening there and there's one more a
little bit tricky rule that students
have learned and it's called the two-way
marking what they learn is that some
words are said one way in speech but
then they're said another way to spell
them and the best example I can give of
that for you as an adult is the word
Wednesday a lot of us learned that to
set it Wednesday
but we spelled it wet nest day so we
learned a funny way to pronounce it to
spell it so here are just a couple
examples of that the word is pronounced
in speech as again but students will
learn and it's it is a two-way word and
they will pronounce it a gain and then
they will mark it with that funny speech
then they'll go back because that's not
the way we we talk they'll go back and
they'll add a little cap above the two
parts of that word that were pronounced
in a different way here's another
example like that we say said but
students will learn to memorize and to
pronounce this as fade and then they
know this two letter phone again
phonogram a two letter a that we do not
use at the end of English words gets an
underline and because of that funny
change that we made to pronounce it it's
going to also get a little cap at the
top so all things that your student has
spent the beginning of the school year
if they were a kindergartner
and if they were a 1st through 6th 8th
grader just incorporated throughout
their day and built upon if they've been
at the school for any length of time but
all things that they know and if you
want to be able to help with practicing
and reviewing spelling words that are
important for you to know as well I hope
that this will help it will provide you
with a way to work with your student and
understand what they have learned
throughout the year so thank you
you